[Music]
don't reach for the wrong child
we are in a tree watching bodies in the
breeze with full fat skirts and sweet
decrees of Seduction
champagne eyes reductions and midnight
gasoline Sabrina in a tree coffee up a
sleeve smoking alive
[Music]
took back all the power
star using Morse code on the sixth car
from a vantage view of the stable Moon
Sabrina you've seen this
[Music]
short 54 short of tennis bats fantasies
prep for the bell of the bull with the
spring and the step a summer was a movie
star and television never went fast
[Music]
watching bodies in the breeze so full
flat skirts and sweet decrees of
Seduction
champagne ice reductions at midnight
gasoline Sabrina in a tree coffee
[Music]
see how she took back all the power
from a vantage view of the stable Moon
[Music]
54 short of tennis bats fantasies prep
for the bell of the bull with the spring
in the step
summer was a movie star and television
never went fast
[Music]
foreign
I don't know
[Music]